hello friends and family who aren't
actually family they're just friends or
family who watch my stuff thank you for
watching and before we get started I
want to tell you this video is brought
to you by loot crate loot crate you know
loot crate is the monthly subscription
where you subscribe and then every month
I send you a box that's full of
something as a theme of some sort full
of stuff we don't need but we love to
have I wanted to give this video to you
all before I started reviewing movies in
2016 this is surprisingly a lot of
people requested me to do this video and
these are the movies that I'm looking
forward to in 2016 and keep in mind
these are in no particular order it's
like the number 10 on the list isn't the
one I'm looking forward to least it's
just I'm kind of going through the order
of release throughout the year of 2016
and keep in mind this is just ten of
them there are a lot of movies I'm
looking forward to in 2016 I mean I
could have made the top 25 30 maybe 40
movies so I'm looking forward to in 2016
this is just 10 so even if it's not on
this list it doesn't mean I'm not
looking forward to it it's just the 10
that at least have my interest you know
I don't know that they're gonna be the
best and yes these are all like really
big budget movies that are high-profile
and they're on my radar because of that
so people who are like Jarrod is like a
big blockbuster movies you're gonna have
fun with this video look at I say it's
easy to look forward to those movies I
have fun with those movies I know for a
fact there are going to be movies that
are gonna be in my top 10 list of 2016
that aren't even on my radar but that's
why they're Gems it's the beauty of that
stuff it's the beauty of the little
movie that comes out of nowhere
that's not on your radars like hey boom
I was great but by definition I'm not
even gonna know about those movies at
this point so sit back relax and try to
have fun with this video have fun with
this list there's a January we know
January's full of [ __ ] I'm not gonna
count the revenant because of evidence
ultimately a 2015 movie so moving on to
February February 12 deadpool comes out
i'm looking forward to this because we
have a lot of people have wanted a
deadpool movie for a very long time and
we didn't really get deadpool in x-men
origins Wolverine but we all were like
Ryan Reynolds is a good choice for
Deadpool that's just not him and now
Deadpool the marketing for Deadpool
first of all has been fantastic it looks
like they're doing Deadpool how they
should dead the pool and now we're
actually getting dead bolt if this
Deadpool movie sucks I don't think
there's gonna be another Mulligan I
think we just kind of lay Deadpool to
rest but if it is as kick-ass as I hope
it is a lot more Deadpool stuff I just
want to see him break that fourth wall I
want to see Deadpool grab a boom
I'm telling you off screen and just beat
someone to death with it next one on the
list March 25th that's right Batman vs
Superman I really want to see this the
first trailer I enjoyed the newest
trailer that we got I wasn't really a
fan of the trailer people seem to take
that as I think the movies gonna suck
ass I don't it's Batman and Superman I
wanted to see that for a long time and
now we're finally getting that I'm just
hoping it's Batman versus Superman not
so much dawn of Justice because if we
have hey what do you want to see Batman
vs Superman or you want to see the
Justice League get together I want to
see Batman fight Superman I just do the
third and definitely not last comic book
movie on my list is May 6 we have
Captain America Civil War I read the
Civil War comic book I loved it this
looks like a smaller scale version of
that event with different logistics
attached to it no such a huge fan of
Captain America Winter Soldier it looks
like a proper sequel to that story arc
and then you have Iron Man vs. Captain
America they've been setting this up for
a while you know these two of Clash when
they've gotten on-screen together it's a
perfect conflict that's been building
throughout a few years of this Marvel
Cinematic Universe now we get to we get
to see it come to a head I really feel
like someone's gonna die in this movie I
just don't know who and in May 27th we
have x-men apocalypse I have been a fan
of the Bryan Singer x-men movies since
x-men 1 Days of Future past showed me he
has not lost his touch and it even
served as a way to just kind of scrub
away the crappy x-men movies that we
don't want to remember and I know people
have complained about how apocalypse
looks in this movie say what you want
about how apocalypse looks the fact is
Oscar Isaac is a kick-ass
actor and I think he's going to be great
as apocalypse Bryan Singer is a great
x-men director I think he's gonna do
great in directing this newest
installment in the x-men franchise
interesting thing deadpool comes out
before x-men apocalypse and Colossus is
in Deadpool Zoe I mean it does show that
Deadpool and x-men do take place in the
same universe I wonder if Deadpool
somehow is probably not going to play
into it at all but be interesting if he
does alright on June 10th we have
Warcraft and now the trailer to Warcraft
it was interesting enough it wasn't
mind-blowing but I am interested in the
movie like I said this is a list of
movies that I either think look great or
I'm at least interested for one reason
or another this movie looks interesting
because so far video game movies have
not had a great track record and I feel
like if Warcraft sucks then they should
just stop trying
Sasson screed also comes out this year I
didn't put it on the list but it
ultimately serves the same thing it's
like if Warcraft sucks we do have
Assassin's Creed that might still hold
on but I'm telling you if these two
don't work let's just stop trying all
together but the director of moon and
source code is taking on the source
material of Warcraft I feel like that
one could be a great one fingers crossed
June 17th one week after Warcraft we now
have finding dory alright Pixar sequel I
mean Cars 2 is probably my least
favorite Pixar movie ever but I feel
like with finding dory it's coming out
what a decade after finding Nemo I feel
like they really do feel like they have
a story to tell with this one Toy Story
sequels were great I hope this goes the
route of the Toy Story sequels and we
walk out of that kon holy crap that was
fantastic oh my god I loved it again
that is a fun thing about doing lists
like this we don't know it's not like
I've seen a trailer for finding dory
watch finding Dory trailer comes out as
I'm editing this I just know Finding
Nemo is great and so I'm hoping that
translates into the world of finding
dory alright August 5th bring on the
Suicide Squad I want to see this for
wonder it's really funny about Suicide
Squad it's like they're building up the
dawn of Justice the Avengers took a few
movies to get going and then we finally
got into Avengers movies like suicide
squads like yeah they're kind of the
[ __ ] so we can just kind of start it
out with them I really want to see this
group of criminals come together and
work for Argus and they have to take out
the Joker played by Jared Leto
I think margot robbie looks awesome as
Harley Quinn and I'm a huge Joker fan
there you go so I want to see Jared
Leto's take on the Joker I think he's a
great actor for the role there are
theories going around like maybe he's
Jason tonight honestly I'd almost be
fine with that
I feel like anything's possible with the
Suicide Squad and you know we have a new
Joker I interested
alright July 1st this one might surprise
you all The BFG The BFG is one of those
books that my first-grade teacher read
to the class when I was a kid I just
remembered it for the rest of my life
and Steven Spielberg's directing
ultimately it takes place in a world
where there are a bunch of giants in
their own land and they come to our land
to eat people but there's just one
friendly one and he gives people dreams
and his girl named Sophie sees him and
so he's like oh you can't see me and he
grabs her and so he takes her on an
adventure to giant lands it's one of
those childhood stories I just want to
see brought to the big screen the guy
that have playing The BFG is perfect
he's a little spy dude from
bridge of spies even if the movies
horrible I am probably still going to
professor he's perfect as The BFG
November 4th dr. strange I was already
interested in dr. strange and they got
Cumberbatch to be dr. strange
I love Cumberbatch so I was like all
right now I'm more interested in doctors
dr. strange is magic I mean we have the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that kind of
establishes alright we kind of imbue
people with magic and age of Ultron I
don't know if they're going that router
that he legitimately finds legit magic
but you saw that one promo picture of
Cumberbatch as Doctor Strange and more
than any other promo pic I've ever seen
of anyone in a very long time I was like
that is Stephen [ __ ] strange that is
a legit pic and ever since that picture
came out it was just on the forefront of
my 2016 list and we're killing off this
list with one you knew was coming this
is rogue one I don't know if it's rogue
one or Star Wars rogue one point is
rogue one is the beginning paragraph of
the opening crawl of the original Star
Wars it says something like it's a
period of Civil War
rebel starships striking from a secret
hidden base of one their first victory
against the evil Galactic Empire
something to that effect I may get the
plans to the Death Star I'm looking
forward to seeing a war movie set in the
Star Wars universe and these people who
just come across these Death Star plans
they're like oh my god we have to get
these two the princess and I am hoping
for the big scenario folks I'm hoping
for that one were these two people or
one person has to get away with the
plans and the rest of them just hold the
line and take out as many stormtroopers
as they can and sacrifice themselves so
that one person can get away with the
plans and bring it to the rebels I want
to cry I want to weep I want to walk out
of there not being okay for like a week
I want to be that destroyed by the end
of this movie and yes but that means
when the trailer drops for this movie
the star wars curtain cape is coming
back I'm gonna snap that baby on tight
around the neck I'm going to talk about
the trailer and oh my god time flies
those are the ten movies that I'm
looking forward to in 2016 now those
again I'm looking forward to about 30
movies but those are the 10 that I kind
of picked for one reason or another kind
of illustrates what I'm looking forward
to in 2016 I mean I'm still looking
forward to ghostbusters I'm looking
forward to Assassin's Creed I'm looking
forward to quite a few movies I weren't
on this list but you know time is time
and numbers are numbers and I wanted to
keep it at 10 and remember this video is
brought to you by loot crate with the
theme of invasion
this month's theme is invasion the
monsters and aliens that invaders try to
destroy us or enslave us and this alters
that fight them off the corporal Hicks's
that live through the movie only to die
in the third one before the credits even
roll you can enter promo code Jeremy
Johnson save yourself ten percent
everyone lives saving themselves from
ten percent but I have a link below that
will take you to Luke right and you can
subscribe to your Luke rate anticipate
invasion all right guys so what 10
movies or 15 or 20 or whatever what
movies are you looking forward to in
2016 whatever their comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more